this injection against flu and measles
could make the difference between life
and death it's early in the morning but
the first patients are already arriving
at this makeshift Medical Center the
refugees do their best to describe their
symptoms and they're grateful for any
help they receive secure games they
understand why we immunize them this
mother has just had her two children
vaccinated against measles the medical
staff are seeing more and more cases of
the virus especially in children they
fear could be the start of an epidemic
so that people are living here all
penned up in extremely cramped
conditions it's all all it takes is for
someone to cough measles is a highly
infectious virus and the people living
here under these conditions are weak
sajan papa de trabajo survival to
infection Don secondo strong bond strong
only preferably of everyone voila more
and more refugees are making the gone
send camp in northern France their home
around 2500 people mostly Kurds are
housed in these dilapidated tents and
makeshift shelters conditions are
deplorable azim is from Iraq he says he
fled from aggressive police officers in
the port city of cali now he lives here
like thousands of others in mud and
squalor medical staff say that because
the French government is doing nothing
to help doctors without borders have had
to build their own tensity the new
settlement features sturdy tents and
proper sanitation so this is one of
around 500 permanent tents on that
ground it's actually the very first time
that doctors without borders are
intervening in France with a
construction of a permanent humanitarian
camp
the organization has invested around 2
million euros in the camp the local
government approved its construction and
set aside the land work on the site is
progressing quickly it'll be equipped
with modern amenities to improve the
lives of the camp's residents Napa's a
legit extended across the entire site
we've laid down a permeable membrane and
a mixture of sand that will prevent mud
forming and coming to the surface we've
also installed proper street lighting
along the entire length of the camp
that's very important in order to
increase security you a little bit
residents in gone sent are not pleased
about another camp in their backyard
many are critical of the town's mayor
for laying out the welcome mat for the
new arrivals p they shouldn't know long
we've had enough of them and their
aggressive behavior Oh case you're more
faithful bunnell we've had to foot the
bill it's caused us money but you're
pregnant is up Rococo vessel copy deja
la la get home there's a war on where
they come from and they brought a bit of
it here two days you see despite the
cuddly toys the original camp at dawn
sent is no place for young children the
new site will offer them safety but at
the moment life here is dangerous too
it's unclear whether the refugees will
be here long enough to see the
completion of the new camp many want to
make it to Britain as soon as possible